Kos Alex nasta who is an immigration
liberalized uh had a pretty good Twitter
thread over the weekend um
contextualizing all of this stuff and uh
even in the middle of that he had this
following thing that caught my eye quote
the Immigration Court backlog is
currently about 3.3 million those
migrants are going to be waiting working
and living in the United States for a
long time and many won't leave even if
the court orders them to go end quote
that's just C crazy untenable isn't it I
mean not just as a as a kind of
practical thing but uh certainly as a
political thing yeah I mean Alex is
basically always right about everything
with respect to immigration I I
associate myself with him I can't think
of a time that he's been wrong so um I
think that you know his persistent
efforts to point out what the status quo
really is um are really important like
they're here they're already here and
and that's again why I think this
Invasion language is so weird and so
unhelpful it's it's not it's not like
this isn't a marzex situation it's not a
Mars attack situation and uh you know
the Martians are already among us I
guess and it's fine um it's more like
Alien Nation which was itself an
extended sci-fi parable about
immigration assimilation great movie
with Mand K tinin so as with actual
aliens when when they come we would be
better off to welcome them to talk with
them to have them uh you know to treat
them with respect uh to not have them
risk their lives to come here uh I can't
I can't speak to how the actual Alien
Invasion is going to go but we already
know what happens when we let people in
and uh you know when we let people in in
a as you know Nick is correct to note
that the border is a mess but one
solution which I know is not on the
table right now in our current political
climate like one solution one way to
prevent a a messy deadly confusing
politically polarizing playable disaster
at the border is to just let people come
here to just make the doors of legal
entry like to throw them open wider and
it doesn't mean we have to let every
single person come here although I think
maybe that would still be the way
honestly but the vast majority of people
who don't have communicable diseases
don't have
take your asist and leave like I like I
just think in the end uh if if we are
looking for a solution to This truly
horrible situation both at the border
and all these people who are living
within the country who are being told at
any time you know maybe your status will
be revoked maybe you will have to be
thrown out maybe you'll have to choose
between staying where your life is and
going into hiding or going back to a
place that you left for a reason um I I
just think that we could just choose
more openness that is really an option
and I think the only morally defensible
one but I also think a really pragmatic
one I I genuinely think that this is
doable um and Alex as usual has like
some excellent concrete steps that we
could take including stuff like you know
getting the you simplifying and speeding
up the the paperwork backlog for people
who are already here one of the points
that Alex makes in that post that is
very good is that this is a demand issue
and this is a demand side issue because
the US economy is in some ways with
regards to the job market actually doing
pretty well um and and like there are
there are a lot of job openings
especially for lower skilled labor and
so people want to come here and so to me
the the operating metaphor here is not
um movies from the 1990s about um alien
detectives or um alien invasions instead
it's prohibition and and people resist
this metaphor when it comes to
immigration because they see it as
something fundamentally different but
it's really this it's really very
similar in so many ways because there is
a demand for something um with
prohibition it was alcohol uh with
immigration it is good jobs and a better
life for your family and that demand is
not going to go away just because you
try to put an artificial barrier in in
the way of it right instead people are
going to try um they're going to try to
get it through means that are more
dangerous and more chaotic and it's
going to create a secondary Market in
violence and criminality that is what
happened in prohibition and it's what
what is happening with the border and if
you want to Tamp down on crime and if
you want to uh make it harder for uh for
for people for gang members and violent
people to come in uh to cross the border
then what we need to do is we need to
say people who are obviously peaceful
and just want to come here and work and
contribute to the economy they can come
in and there's an easy and
straightforward process for them to do
that and then we're going to focus our
efforts on catching the actual bad guys
who want to come over here and do bad
stuff it'd be nice to hear uh president
you know who has the bully pulpit really
come out and say exactly that That We're
a nation of immigrants uh and that
everybody who wants to live and work
peacefully is welcome here it does cause
disruption we're going to meter it out
so it's not you know like a billion
people coming in the first year or
anything like that but we're going to
expedite it right now as much as
anything and this is true not just of
immigration but it's true of Economics
it's true of foreign policy we don't
have a national meta narrative of like
what is America about and as a result
you start to see uh people knock off
things U Force Republicans to say that
they don't want anybody new in the
country because things are perfect the
way they are Force left-wingers to admit
that we cannot admit people and you know
that not that this happens but it's the
fear you can't just bring in a lot of
people who are immediately going to go
on welfare roles which by the way if we
continue with current Asylum policy if
you bring people in and they can't work
that's like up beyond belief let
people come here and live and work
openly and honestly they don't get
welfare they don't necessarily get
citizenship but they do get legal status
and they're going to move into the parts
of the country where there are
opportunity and that will take care of
all sorts of problems rather than cause
any but we we need to be talking about
why immigration is important to the
country not just in economic terms uh
but also in kind of national and
identity terms and we also need to talk
about the the fears that people have
where you know part of this is a larger
anxiety that's throughout the country in
all different ways about the future
about how things are shifting radically
out of the world that most of us grew up
in and didn't like when we had it we
wanted it to change but now we look back
nostalgically as if you know the 1970s
uh when immigration was very low is
somehow a good thing I mean fashion yes
it was a great thing the 19 and it's
pretty good in music under represented
yeah uh prog rock and bell bottoms bring
them back Matt likes the colors elephant
elephant bottoms bell bottoms H elephant
bottoms